of all the places I've been and stories
I've covered for Sky News my trip to the
island of Tanna who was probably my
favorite it was Prince Philip's 90th
birthday and I wanted to celebrate with
the tribe who worship Him as a god the
strange tale of devotion to a Greek born
British royal has its roots in a local
legend of a volcano which gave birth to
a white man who married a queen the
local chief sent her traditional club to
Buckingham Palace as a gift and when the
Duke sent back a picture of him holding
it his status as a deity was confirmed
for my trip I brought with me some
Philips souvenirs and a biography which
rather contradicts the tribes beliefs
the people of Yunnan and village always
hoped their prince would come to visit
but the news of his withdraw from public
life ends that dream in 2011 they had to
make do with me performing the opening
ceremony for a new shrine perhaps
they'll invite me back again as a mortal
stand-in for the man they call a God in
woods
Sky News no longer in Vanuatu